we're here with a top theoretician
linear dominguez that was a crazy draw
you just had
how does it feel you won a brilliancy
price with this variation already and
you decided to go into it again yeah i
mean it's uh obviously very
tricky line for black i knew it was a
draw but i thought that in rapid chess
and
it's kind of hard to to find all the
moves or even even if you know them
which you're supposed to know but still
you have to remember and it's not so
simple but he
i mean he did all right and i think uh
yeah there was nothing to do yeah he
played this move queen e8 which was
definitely uh the improvement from your
game of course against maxima sherlock
at the same field cup but you still kept
some pressure yeah i mean after rook d1
of course is the logical move and then
uh yeah black has to go rook c7 and it
looks very
uh
i mean dangerous for black because he
kind of moved the bishop and i'm
opening the h file
but uh yeah it's just move per move here
this d5 and queen c6 i think it's very
precise i think queen a8 is also
probably fine but but d5 and queen e5
and then i think the critical moment
what was after
hd fg rook h7 gregor schlem was great i
was on the playing hall and you went for
your rook took on h7 your opponent
seemed a bit surprised and this move
bishop a4 how did you even come up with
this idea uh yeah i mean i thought that
uh
it's possible but uh
black smooths black's moves after that
are not that difficult i mean rook f7
and so it's the only move but it's it's
such an obvious move so i wasn't sure if
uh if i should go for this or or to play
uh instead of bishop a4 rook h1 and rook
h6
i believe it's also
objectively equal and now bishop f6 is
the correct move not such a simple move
but uh black doesn't have many moves
anyway
and after df6 rook f6 i didn't really
see
how i'm playing for a win here i thought
that potentially this could be of course
tricky for me so i went for the other
line which uh
i mean i i saw it was just a draw
absolutely topsy-turvy day today had a
tough one in round two how do you feel
at the end of today yeah i mean it's uh
i mean wasn't the best day in the world
for me but uh it's the first day so our
main thing was just to to
get into and to practice a little bit
and hopefully
tomorrow will be better linear dominguez
looking for those brilliancy prices well
let's see what happens in the last game
remaining in today's round back to the
studio alejandro if you may ask lanier
for a quick
question about the whole magnus and how
he feels as an international grand
master world class player magnus
stepping down from the world
championship match
we wanted to ask you as well we had big
news today
magnus carlsen won't be defending his
world championship title your thoughts
yeah i mean initially i thought it's uh
that's not really going to happen but
yeah it's it's for real so
i guess uh
he has his reasons uh it's very
interesting because he seems to do what
nobody else does
so
yeah in a way i think
i can understand that the pressure of
defending the the title when there is a
possibility obviously that you can lose
takes a lot of
energy and it's stressful and all that
and he yeah he just wants to
to play without pressure just to play
tournaments so i can
i can see that i mean it's uh
obviously
uh strange in the sense that if you're
the best player in the world you you you
should play normally and and and and
you have many things to achieve like
legacy and stuff like that but yeah i
guess it's his decision and uh
it's an interesting one seems like it
comes to as a shock to you
yeah well i
at some point i mean at the beginning i
thought it was just uh he's uh
just kidding a bit i mean he was maybe
messing with the other players and the
candidates because psychologically it
also put some pressure on some people
but then i realized that maybe he's uh
is for real so it's uh yeah it's an
interesting decision absolutely and
today well confirmation for real magnus
carlsen will not be defending well thank
you lanier and good luck the rest of the
tournament thank you
thank you lanier i always interestingly
hear the perspectives